okay soft the studio but before I go I'm
starting to really get into these enemy
sunglasses yeah this is alpha M steel
two choices for today
diggin these but also like these not bad
hmm I look spectacular I'm going with
these today anyways look you want to get
a great deal on these use the wonderful
20 code and check out Alpha M's new
enemies yeah he's got enemies you get it
I'm not his enemy anymore even though I
kicked his ass off shark tank twice but
check out the shades I look spectacular
[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of S mr. wonderful and this
one's very special because I've got
fellow shocked Antonian Mark Cuban here
with me we're working in New York
talking about moving shark tank back to
Friday night so we're doing a lot of
promotion but while we're here in a
studio which we're in the green room I
thought what a great chance to ask a few
questions fire white cast though I've
been all around the world on this one so
here we go we'll get right to it mark
this one is from niche in Oxford England
okay okay you ready
you should he got hello mr. wonderful
Nishio from Oxford my questions here is
that what do you think the future of
blockchain and cryptocurrencies are okay
mark that's perfect for you blockchain
and crypto currencies a lot of people
think they're [ __ ]
so blockchain is different than
cryptocurrencies right blockchain is a
feature of crypto currencies but not all
crypto currencies are used just for
blockchain so let's take them in two
pieces crypto how much of your DoDEA of
tied up in crypto currency so you think
it's [ __ ] um I don't know that it's
[ __ ] but you have to ask how to
value it and people value it in
different ways particularly blockchain I
mean particularly Bitcoin so with
Bitcoin some people value it as a store
of value yeah which makes it like
baseball cards art gold and they have
value they have value because people see
value in and not
because they have insurance oh you say
they have no intrinsic value what is the
intrinsic value of gold
I mean minimal intrinsic value for
manufacturing and jewelry but not enough
to justify the price of gold that's
typically that it typically trades that
they're the Delta between the intrinsic
value the manufacturing / jewelry and
what it's being sold for what's being
valued out on markets is what they call
store value because people want to
invest in it because they think if
certain circumstances occur that it like
a pandemic for whatever it may be yeah
that people other other there will be
potential buyers at that value so they
see it as storing value and they do it
go sounds like you prefer to own gold to
store value than crypto I prefer neither
right now okay because I've never been a
gold fan because the like I said the
delta between intrinsic and trading
value is what people invest and see in
it but it's no different than tulips
it's no different than baseball cards
it's no different than a lot of
different things because it's only worth
what you think someone else will pay
you're basically saying it's a
speculation yeah of course okay let's
talk about blockchain to me that is
actually a non proprietary utility right
why would that in any way be a storage
of value blockchain anyway blockchain
effectively a software okay so the
distributed database that's managed
independently and that inherently that
inherent combination makes it a utility
it makes it software effectively that
has value in utils so when somebody's
running around trying to raise a
blockchain fund that's just a software
for higher fund in some respects that
you know but there's a specific you
there are there are very unique use
cases for blockchain so for instance
when when people say there's no value at
knowing no intrinsic value to crypto
they're they don't really look at the
value of blockchain now when you take
block chains from different types of
cryptocurrency Bitcoin versus aetherium
versus others there's their significant
differences but block taint blockchain
in general does have
at least a basic intrinsic value not as
high as what the kryptos trade for but
there is basic contrition value and I'll
give you an example if for instance
there was a block chain driven general
ledger system that had auditing
capabilities so for instance for a big
company you wanted to have a truly
independent auditor that would so you
would set up a general ledger system
using block chains with where an
external third party would be able to
look at different segments of the
general ledger but there won't just be
one auditor you can have leads the
process more efficient so it has value
there but it makes it not just more
efficient but it makes it then truly
independent but there's no equity that I
can buy in block well but let me finish
imagine if this was the system used for
Enron yeah so that instead of having
Arthur Andersen doing their auditing and
their accounting and we know what
happened from there the auditors and the
accountants were there were three
different auditors and accountants that
using blockchain were able to look at a
specific segment of their general ledger
and a six so they would have caught the
fraud way early they would have caught
the fraud because you couldn't you
couldn't you couldn't fake out all three
of them so it has utility there I guess
yeah thank you nice very interesting
let's have a look at number two here I
got some very interesting questions for
you might wanna be honest with you
you're gonna find this different all
right
dolorous ready mr. wonderful I love you
you're my favorite shark operator about
as a an entrepreneur just starting out
I've been told that I need to that it
would be good to raise money from
friends and family and I don't have the
type of friends and family though that
can you know give me I don't have a
marketing money to start my venture I'm
working really hard but I don't come
from that type of socio-economic level
where you know friends can get and
family can give me money so what do I do
if you know I
being told by everyone Oh friends and
family first but most of those people
that are saying that have friends and
family who have been able to give them
you know sizable amounts of money but
for those of us who don't have that
those means and those contacts what do I
do
hey thanks a lot so much you didn't have
a wonderful oh thank you I appreciate
that you talk about your past a lot
nobody gave you a lot of dough what's
the answer this woman's question you
don't raise money sweating sweat equity
is the best equity you start smaller you
know there are most businesses I'd say
at least ninety if not 95% or more
percentage of small businesses startups
can start without raising any capital at
all you just use sweat equity now
obviously we don't know what kind of
business she's trying to start but you
just have to try to start smarter with
smaller the hard part for most people is
that trade-off between do I keep my job
or how do I start a company when I have
a job most people feel like they need to
raise money so they can quit their jobs
you advocate they quit their job now say
go make it happen get some revenue we
improve it at work there's a bartender
at night I mean whatever you have to do
that's part of being an entrepreneur so
if you have to work on weekends you have
to uber at night uber on weekends so you
have some income coming in so you can
work on your your company or you work
your regular job during the week and at
night and weekends that's when you work
on your star so the good news there is
anybody can be an entrepreneur if
they're willing to work their ass off
for 24 hours that's what it takes I
think that's your message so you know
like they always say entrepreneurs work
80 hours so they don't have to work 40
all right good one thank you next Cooper
hey mr. wonderful this is Cooper from
Missouri I'm 19 and I'm in my second
semester at college and I haven't really
decided on a major yet I mean I'm
thinking law school just because I like
arguing and I like
like business and shark tank is my
favorite show and obviously you're my
favorite shark
but I was just wondering in your expert
opinion and this time an era what would
be a good degree to get like maybe a
major and a minor to apply to law school
or even your opinion on just a career
outside of no law school with just a
degree thank you
Oh Cooper I'm gonna give you a hell of a
deal today because you got two sharks
for the price of one mark this is a
question you must get all the time of
course I mean this is guidance for the
next generation what do you say to
Cooper first of all Cooper notice and
you know as a potential lawyer potential
entrepreneur you have to pay attention
to the details notice the first thing
mr. wonderful does he asked me he
doesn't answer I'm trying to be polite
next time no more mr. wife and I'll tell
you that right now but here's your
answer Cooper you don't have to figure
it out when you're 19 I started off as
an accounting major I realized that was
awful I didn't want to do audits of
furniture and carpet spools and changed
my major multiple times I knew I wanted
to be in business I just didn't know
what the details were going to be so
don't stress about it but take a lot of
different types of business classes
because when you're learning how to
learn and you're experiencing different
parts of business you'll find something
that sticks with you and by the time you
need to declare a major or even if it
takes you a little bit longer you'll
know more then you can decide if you
should be a lawyer if you should be an
accountant if you should be in finance
marketing you said you want to start a
business you know if you're you know
take some entrepreneurship classes you
want to be rich you know in order to get
there and be prepared to start a
business if you're going through college
take as many you take marketing take
accounting take finance those are all
the languages of business take you know
technology classes because these are the
things you're gonna have to learn no
matter what so you experience different
things Cooper try it all and then you'll
be in a better position to the side and
I will add to that example within my
universe and you actually know Alex
Kenji he's a lawyer he was an IP lawyer
but he's also an entrepreneur he
combined the two together and now he
runs o'leary ventures
and alex has done very very well working
with us on shark tank over the last
decade
he owns 15% of every deal I do and I
love the money that's how I do it so
he's putting his own Kahuna's on the
line and if he doesn't put that loan in
place
I don't close cuz Alex does all the due
diligence with your guys - Stephen
that's how we do it those guys work
together with Alex own you oh you know a
lot of attention servitude because I
ain't doing the deal unless he's fully
engaged but that's a cool thing thank
you for that Cooper that's wonderful to
hear
next we've got Theresa don't you love
these international type question yes -
it's cool
hello mr. wonderful my name is Theresa
black I own a more a con gelato a
company that makes food they sweeten
gelato I am growing quickly and everyone
who tastes my product loves it but I
would like to know how do I get the
right people to taste it so that I can
grow faster
how do I even know who the right people
are and how do I find you know I got to
tell you something mark if she doesn't
make it the gelato business she's gonna
make she's making a radio yeah really
it's a beautiful voice Therese you have
but mark you've been doing a lot of food
deals at Shark Tank in the last year and
there's a lot of Theresa's to get in
front of you and pitch you right yeah I
actually did a deal called one a date
with aunt Renee Melissa and she's got a
date spread which is incredible it's the
benefit of date versus just cane sugar
um well first of all it's natural and so
you're not you're not getting any added
sugars second of all particularly her
date spread well um one a date is
relatively low calorie it's only 25
calories from the area of the natural
day another merit of it and third it's
got great nutrients I'm a big believer
you try to get all your RDA allowance of
nutrients and vitamins from foods as
opposed to I remember that deal now I
said better ones with just the milk of a
camel and dates could live forever
exactly right you have it but you didn't
answer a question right how does she get
this great product this date based
gelato in front of people how do you get
out of there well obviously not knowing
what market she's in it's hard to give
her specifically speak but generally
speaking that's where you go to farmers
markets that's where you go to flea
markets that's where you go anywhere
where people are going to be at and you
sell right you make it that morning you
freeze it and you take it out there get
yourself a refrigerator or freezer
whatever you got to hump it out there
you've got to hump it but then initially
you do it all yourself so you can learn
about your product and get feedback and
one thing you need to do is collect
email addresses right because you won
right right you might be an email dating
database so that you can email them and
say here's my website and you know
because you're local I can deliver it to
you and sell it to you at a premium
price because it sounds like a premium
product part two to that is even though
it seems like a real grind to do flea
markets etc you know farmers markets
find some college kids some high school
kids that can work for you you know at
ten twelve whatever dollars an hour or
maybe Commission and get them out there
doing the same thing so you have a
network of people then hopefully you
build up enough demand collect enough
email
dresses that you could have the first
date gelato route right so that people
are getting these things delivered then
I once you have a base and you have data
and you have sales and you're you've
started to grow and you understand
what's involved in growing your business
because it's hard to grow a food
business like that in terms of you know
making it and distributing it then I
would go to the local grocery stores
that deliver and even find the local
regional head for Whole Foods who then
may be able to offer to through Amazon
Prime be on Amazon fresh because they
can deliver within two hours frozen
products and like I'll order frozen
products through Amazon all the time so
that way you can start building up even
larger local trade then you'll see the
progression and if you can accomplish to
the point where you're being delivered
by Amazon fresh through Whole Foods then
the sky's the limit so Teresa Cuban just
gave you your business plan now chop
chop get to work and start going those
farmers markets that's what it's about
it's just grinding your job in radio
yeah boy is that what a beautiful voice
you have that's just crazy alright next
up on the hit parade
we've got Rohan Reddy on yeah
hello mr. wonderful everyone in business
says that you should find out what
you're good at
I mean stick with that in business but
my question is how do you actually
discover what you're good at and what
you're gonna do well mark that's a good
one for you again because you suck at
everything and somehow you made money
I'm great at a couple things that's all
it takes I'll tell you a quick story
Rohan um when I went to college I took
one technology class and I cheated at it
it was a Fortran programming class but
that was basically I just asked for help
and I really didn't ever think
technology would be a strength for me
you said you became a coder you were
actually coding then I went out of
college then I moved to Dallas and I was
working as a bartender slash bar back at
night and got a job working for a
software store during the day and the
guy asked me I'm like you don't know a
lot about software so what are you going
to do I'm like I'll teach myself he's
like how are you going to teach yourself
and I told him I'd read the manual and
that's exactly what I did I've worked in
this store during the day quit my job
bartending at night
then at night I would take home one of
their computers because I went to
RadioShack to buy a computer and they
turned out my credit so I would take one
of the computers that they had taken
home and just work all night saved up
even to passion about it the point is
you gotta find something you love to do
that well yeah because then the bigger
point is I didn't even know that I was
gonna be passionate about computers
until I got a job at a computer store
and so the point about it is you're
gonna have to try a lot of different
things you don't you're not going to
know but eventually you'll come across
something that not only that you'd like
to do but that you can be good at and
once you find something you'd like to do
and that you're good at it
then try to be great at it because if
you could be great at it
a nobody quits anything they're great at
and B that's where you find your chance
to make a lot of money great advice
brilliant gut go out there and do it
very interesting on alright next shaggy
that's interesting ready for shaggy mark
hey mr. wonderful shaggy from New Jersey
I was wondering what you thought about
the space tourism industry do you think
it's a viable industry to invest in or
do you think it's all hype and it'll
take many decades for it to be an actual
viable business thank you for your time
another Cuban question space exploration
you know there's a stock that's on fire
Galactic makes no money got a lot of
orders risky is held if you're getting
in there yeah would you pay 250 to go up
in that thing me no because I'm
terrified of heights but shaggy let me
just say it wasn't me I had to get that
in there sorry I think it's a legitimate
industry we just don't know who the
winners are going to be yet and so
people will pay for tourism space
tourism obviously it's going to be
expensive but it's all relative being
able to go up in a rocket right is going
to be of interest to people who can
afford it but like that thrill you know
and so if how big a market is that I
don't know how do you start a company
there you're going to need a lot of
capital to do that and you're gonna be
able to take on losses you're gonna have
to take on losses for a long time it's
kind of you know Tesla or you know the
board company those are things that are
huge investments but if you can raise
enough money and
stick it out and and having unique
enough advantage in my you know I had a
chest interview Branson you know him as
well and he told me eventually it's not
just tourism because if you can get from
let's say Dallas Texas to Dubai in
two-and-a-half hours twenty seven hours
of course that's pretty good yeah it's
like the old Concorde that's why people
use the car you know at some point you
pay 80 or 100 grand to get that well
yeah there's no there's no asset that's
more valuable than to time so there's
that industries viable okay alright very
interesting next I think this may be our
last one mark I'll be here all day for
you Kevin well am I happy you're doing
that I'm making you do some work finally
that's a good thing hello Kevin my name
is Ian I'm a 38 year old Irish dad
living in Sydney Australia I'm about to
purchase a b2b manufacturing business
for two million dollars I have an
investor who will invest 1 million for
10% ownership I must pay back that 1
million at 8 percent interest plus he
gets 20 percent of the profits
till that 1 million is payback I have 1
million of my own money and I have no
half standing - do you think the scheme
is fair or should I lift the bar from
the bank and have hundred percent
ownership myself well Ian baby you've
come to the right place
you sound like you're paying a royalty
but it's really interesting the loans I
think's going along so first of all mark
let's break it down I mean this is a
deal this guy's got a serious business
here right putting up 2 million bucks
one way or another right a million of
his and potentially a million investor
but it sounds like he's got the
opportunity to borrow from the bank yeah
and so it really comes down to how
profitable is the business if the
business is profitable enough that you
can support the loan you always do the
loan which is $80,000 8% 8% million
dollars right is $80,000 a year
yeah so if he can afford that you do the
loan every time because you can get it's
probably three years max right yeah who
knows of its balloon or whatever maybe
he's in Australia so I don't know all
the all the opportunities there the only
reason you would use the investor is
that he or her what he or she was
strategic in some way so if it's the
same money and they're not strategic you
go with the bank all the time although
they can bankrupt you if you don't pay
their loan back yes
so can investor you know so I mean
you're gonna have an obligation and and
you're probably have to personally
guarantee it one way or the other if
you're confident in the operation if
you're confident and the profits or that
you can increase the profits you go to
the bank but without knowing details the
first red flag that comes up is that
this person is selling you the business
for two million dollars right and so if
it's being sold for two million dollars
it's not probably not generating two
million dollars in profits right so
you're asking yourself what multiple you
would ask the question what multiple of
cash flow are you actually paying for
the company and so is he paying five
times and generating $400,000 in cash
flow or is it some hot trendy business
and he's paying 20 times earnings
because if you're paying two million
dollars for 20 times earnings you're
only making $100,000 and that's before
you pay yourself and if you're paying
80% in interest with either deal right
that's a challenge so the basic message
here from your point of view on this
real deal because 2 million bucks is
going to work as serious money if you
can get it from a bank it has less
covenants and strings probably than the
investor unless their strategic well if
not if not that there's less covenants
or strings it's just that there's no
equity of debt right you're not giving
up anything ok we got one more market I
think you're gonna be a little surprised
on this one
the coronavirus is causing Apple to
shift some of its iPhone production out
of China do you see this as a temporary
measure or a part of a wider trend for
companies overly dependent on one
country for most of their factory labor
and if part of a larger trend what
countries do you think are well poised
to seize the opportunity all right very
current question right we got a virus
pandemic maybe people don't know it's
changing production lines and sourcing a
product in the case of Apple that's a
big deal for China what do you think so
there's three questions there first
going backwards
are there other companies that can act
as hosts for manufacturing and should
you and then number two is should you
invest in placing production there so
every country has its own risk of one
sort or another whether it's Mexico
Indonesia Thailand where
you may choose that has a low most of
them are getting some virus breakout
well put aside the virus right there's
you know cuz you're looking you're
looking forward so there's always going
to be some sort of inherent risk it
could be political it can be economic it
can be any number it can be medical so
there's always going to be risk and so
it would suggest that if you can afford
it that you want to have as many
locations as possible it's almost like a
diversification yeah diversification of
risk so it's almost like cloud computing
you never want to have a vendor who has
all their assets to data centers in just
one location because if something
happens then you're out of business and
manufacturing sim similar but because
supply chains have become so complex and
products ain't no materials come from so
many different locations that really
makes it different to sort difficult to
source and ship all the different
materials to multiple locations unless
you're very big so that's just a
decision each company will have to make
now as far as the coronavirus I'm not an
expert but here's what I've read what
I've read is that it will spread it will
be pandemic and the reason why is
because it's like a serious cold it's
like a light flu and because it's a
respiratory transmission right but but
the real issue is that a lot of people
who have it or asymptomatic it's not so
serious that they even think they're
sick and unless you're some it's death
well but like the flu for some people if
you're older if you're already sick if
your immune system is compromised again
this is just for me reading a couple
articles I'm not an expert um then like
the flu you could have really problems
and so there's a 2% death rate from
corona I don't know what the death rate
is from the flu be particularly cuz
there's vaccines but it's the same type
of risk so where this leads to
because it's easily communicable it will
be a pandemic but whether or not we just
like the flu there's a vaccine but
there's no cure once you get it
it'll become seasonal in other words
it'll we're gonna see this on a rotating
basis that's another flu strain yes
virus somehow we're gonna have maybe
we'll have medicine for it at some point
a vaccine I'm sure at some point we'll
figure it out it takes about a year
yeah we're knows how long but just like
there's a flu season and we know to get
vaccine for the flu season don't be a
corona season and I'm not talking about
with Jimmy Buffett and having a beer
right so it will happen and your best
you know reaction is to stay healthy and
help you know usually be well right and
help your employees and your family do
the same thing because it's happening
has it changed your investment thesis in
any way in terms of what you've done
within your investments already so I'm
not at all
now looking at the market it's been
crushed because people just don't know
and how much it could slow growth in
various recession and economists have
written that it will slow grow some but
I don't see that as a long-term impact
but I think the the scale of the decline
you know the three four whatever percent
has been has as much to do with the fact
that the markets at all-time highs yeah
they need an excuse to do a correction
exactly down about eight percent the
correction would be ten that could
happen the next day or two right and
like I haven't sold anything yeah I get
it and I'm the same way I'm just kind of
riding it up saying I don't know enough
to make an investment decision and you
know over the last three years almost
four years I've increased my clap my
cash as the markets gone up so you know
I'm a Warren Buffett acolyte when
there's blood in the streets then when
you buy that's when you buy and so if
something crazy happens and the market
just goes upside down I'll be lining up
its new you have some powder dry listen
mark has been a fantastic episode of ask
mr. wonderful clearly all these guys
just think I'm the better shark what a
problem yeah four questions can way to
rock it I'm looking forward to taping
shark tank with you in season 12 we're
here any work together what are we doing
why are we here why we're because we're
promoting the fact that shark tank has
moved up Friday nights on ABC
exactly so turn your channel tune in
every Friday night to your local ABC
affiliate if you miss it don't ever
to us again mark I will see you in LA
and I will kick your ass on Shark Tank
yet again for the 12th years after thank
you my dreamer thanks everybody
see you next week